hey guys it's gary vaynerchuk i got
inspired i was clearly doing something
else a few minutes ago
um first of all big shout out to new
york jets playoff beard intact
this sunday peyton manning and the colts
are going down and i'm going to my first
super bowl but what i really want to
talk to you guys about
is consumer expectations i've been
talking about this
quite a bit mainly in the second half of
my book tour some of you might have
heard this if you came out
i'm fascinated by consumer expectations
see
what i know is this in 1998
i did free shipping on winelibrary.com
and people
lost their mind people bought wine for
their daughter's weddings
when their daughters were five years old
because they were so stunned
that they could get free shipping see
they weren't expecting free shipping now
every email you get from a retailer is
free shipping during the holiday season
you all wait for the post black friday
cyber monday deals
expectations change i know that if any
of you went to a hotel right now
and have dial up internet that you would
crap your pants and call all your
friends
and be pissed but only a decade ago
you'd be thrilled
they had internet at all consumer
expectations
now this is where i get really focused
and really intrigued
brands are interacting with people
celebrities are interacting with people
i didn't expect al toone my favorite
jets receiver
10 15 years ago to call me or hit me up
on my pager or ring my doorbell and
high-five me for being a fan
but if i'm a bengals fan there's
probably some form of expectation
that if i hit him up enough on twitter
that chado joe cinco is going to say
what's up
i never expected my favorite bubblegum
bubble yum
to like hit me up and say i hope you
like that flavor bigly chew to say
how's the grape today but i might expect
pillsbury now if i say oh these
pillsbury dough muffins are amazing to
kind of hit me up
give me a coupon say what's going on
expectations of the consumer are going
to change
dramatically over the next 36 months and
brands
companies and personal brands pseudo
celebrities
triple z like me or real big celebrities
are gonna have to adjust and recognize
what this means to their brand and more
importantly to their business
and what it's going to come down to is
the people that can scale their caring
and so if you're not paying attention to
what's starting to happen
right now this new oh my god it's not oh
my god
this celebrity hit me up or oh my god my
favorite sneaker company just said hello
it's yeah and soon it's going to be like
where are you
consumer expectations are going to
change the landscape
very quickly and if you're not ready for
it you're gonna lose